Go back to Minsk. Поверайтеся до Мінська. Вас обманюють білоруські чиновники. Польський кордон закритий.
SMS  з таким сенсом може надійти на мобільний телефон від польського оператора ось тут на так званому перехресті кордонів трьох держав.
Ліворуч приблизно кілометр - це Білорусь. Позаду, теж кілометр - Польща. А це українська прикордонна смуга.
І тут мігрантам з боку Білорусі теж не раді.
Ви не маєте права порушувати закони України. Повертайтеся!
У Волинській області повним ходом йдуть масштабні навчання прикордонників, нацгвардійців та поліцейських.
У Польщі не виключають, що мігранти можуть спробувати прорватися з Білорусі не через польський кордон,
а через український. Українсько-білоруський кордон це приблизно 1000 км.
МВС України та Дежприкордонслужба вважають, що зможуть не допустити перетину кордону групами мігрантів.
До того ж, мігранти перебувають не біля кордону з Україною,
а приблизно за триста кілометрів звідси, тож підготуватися до їхньої появи можна заздалегідь.
Ми розглядаємо певний сценарій, що мігранти в певний час можуть бути спрямовані в бік держкордону України.
Ми розуміємо, що основні пункти, де можуть перетинати, вони в близькості до кордону з Польщею.
Але це мають обов’язково бути дороги, які йдуть до українського кордону.
Тому що лісами пересуватися, щоб пробиралися тисячі людей, неможливо.
Україна ще ніколи не зіштовхувалася з ситуацією, коли мігранти масово штурмують державний кордон.
Наразі спецпризначенці відпрацьовують тактику протидії, що аналогічна тактиці реагування під час масових заворушень.
Це так звані засоби несмертельної дії. Але з різницею в тому, що наступати на порушників вони не можуть.
Якщо будуть летіти коктейлі Молотова та каміння, ми будемо стояти і не відступати назад.
Наша задача - стримати і щоб не перетнули кордон з іншої держави громадяни.
Ми не можемо стріляти. Якщо вони будуть стріляти, то це вже є агресією. Можемо використовувати зброю згідно наказу 200.
Тобто спецпризначенці можуть застосувати зброю лише у разі реальної загрози для свого життя та здоров’я.
Натомість є інші засоби для зупинки порушників кордону. Спецмашини, які можуть швидко копати рови.
Бронетранспортери, якими можна перегородити дороги тощо.
За наказом очільника МВС в прикордонні райони доправлені додаткові 15 вертольотів.
І ще 8000 додаткових спецпризначенців.
На відміну від Польщі, Україна наразі може реагувати на потенційні виклики радше людським ресурсом, аніж інженерно-технічним, якого бракує.
Можливо, ми проведемо інженерні облаштування. Можливо, не такими темпами, як цього хотілось б,
але робимо все, що можливо. На жаль, наші заводи, які виготовляють колючий дріт, наразі відправляють його в Литву, в Польщу.
Але вже зафрахтовані їхні потужності для виготовлення дроту в інтересах ДПС.
Роботи з інженерного облаштування кордону біля Білорусі останніми роками велися епізодично.
Адже кордон не був демаркований і не було юридичних підстав зводити різні інженерні комунікації.
Демаркацію завершили лише минулого року.
Те, що я бачу на сьогодні, то державний кордон, якщо говорити про інженерні споруди, фактично не облаштований.
Вперше прийнято рішення профінансувати в бюджеті наступного року створення інтелектуального кордону з РФ і з республікою Білорусь.
Протягом наступного року ці роботи будуть розпочаті.
Завдання якомога швидко облаштувати кордон поставив перед силовиками президент Володимир Зеленський.
Україна хоче витратити 17 мільярдів гривень на відеомоніторинг кордону і прикордонних територій,
зведення антивандального паркану, контрольної смуги, інших захисних споруд.
Раніше чимало коштів на облаштування українського кордону виділяли країни Євросоюзу.
Тепер деякі європейські політики, приміром, депутат Бундестагу Нільс Шмід, зовнішньополітичний речник найбільшої фракції соціал-демократів,
запропонував  залучити Україну до розв’язання проблеми біженців на кордоні Польщі та Білорусі.
Україна, на його думку, могла б прийняти цих біженців на той час, поки триває розгляд їхньої заявки про надання притулку в ЄС.
На думку Шміда, в цьому випадку Євросоюз би дав чітко зрозуміти,
що не кожен мігрант автоматично потрапляє до ЄС. В Україні з німцями аж ніяк не погоджуються.
У нас є пропозиція соціал-демократам взяти собі трьох-п’ятьох біженців додому.
Якщо мало місця в Бундестазі, в них там є кабінети, то хай беруть до себе і хай вони там знаходяться.
З якого переляку ми маємо їх брати до себе? Якщо німці про них мають піклуватися!?
Дуже дивно, коли німці  починають нам розповідати, що нам з цього приводу робити.
Міністр внутрішніх справ Монастирський заявив, що Україна буде реагувати на появу мігрантів
відповідно до законів України і європейських конвенцій.
Якщо мігранти подають заяву про надання статус біженця, Україна має її розглянути.
Мігранти повинні бути розміщені в пунктах тимчасового перебування і забезпечені усім необхідним до вирішення їхньої подальшої долі.
Ми зможемо захистити держкордон від великих груп  незаконних мігрантів.
Навіть якщо таке станеться, повірте, ми спільно з Нацгвардією, Нацполіцією
зможемо їх виявити в межах прикордонних районів з подальшою передачею на територію Білорусі.
Якщо не зможемо передати по реадмісії, то є основна процедура видворення, до якої залучаються посольства цих країн.
В українських селах впритул до кордону помічають, що атмосфера на кордоні з Білоруссю, де постійно літають військові літаки, дуже напружена.
У селі Вільшанка мешкає усього 70 людей.
Більшість місцевих вже давно виїхали в Білорусь, молодь постійно перебуває на заробітках в ЄС.
Тут не вірять в те, що кілька тисяч мігрантів з країн Близького Сходу та Азії дійдуть до їхніх селищ.
Я нікого не бачив ніколи, і хлопці не бачили. Якщо ми б побачили, то одразу на заставу би!
Я думаю, що цього не допустять, тому що кордони перекриті. Я не хочу думати, що хтось сюди піде!
Що їм сюди йти?! Вони на Німеччину підуть! В таку країну не підуть.
Біля сусіднього села нещодавно затримали двох громадян Куби, які прямували до ЄС.
Згідно з офіційною статистикою Держприкордонслужби, за 9 місяців цього року на всій ділянці кордону з Білоруссю
було затримано усього 13 нелегалів.
Держприкордонслужба та МВС закликали населення до співпраці - моніторити ситуацію в прикордонних районах.
Також до охорони кордону долучають загони територіальної оборони.
Нацгвардія, Нацполіція, СБУ в прикордонних регіонах також уже переведені в посилений режим несення служби.